I'm an English literature student right
now waffling when I see it okay
sometimes this organization drives me
crazy but do I sit there and think
Britain would be better off if we left
absolutely not you can't control freedom
of movement so why did you make that
place because as I said as I say there
have been many years where movements
people out of Britain into Europe out of
Europe into Britain have been broadly in
balance serious you see it happening any
period whilst you're so Prime Minister
next four years I'm not going to put a
date on it leaving the single market
would be an act of economic self harm
for Britain and this would be an act of
economic self harm you will
fundamentally damage our economy
what comes first world war three or the
global brexit recession read my speech
the words world war three never
Neverland is addressing you never forget
that 70 years ago these countries were
fighting each other I don't think we
should take that for granted
do you still think that Boris Johnson's
would make a good Prime Minister I've
said he's been a great mayor of london
he's got plenty of left fuel in the tank
and I'll let other people decide and
that's as far as I'm going to go